Today we do Rome and um so before we've
done Persia
um the Jews and the Greeks and these are
the three um main civilizations after
Brontage collapse and now we will emerge
Rome to eclipse all three and build a
world empire. Okay. And what I will
argue to you today is that Rome is the
great anti-ivilization.
Um or you can call it just the evil
empire. Okay. All right. So what do we
know about Rome? Well, like most great
empires, they emerge initially at the
borderlands
of another cultural empire. Okay. know
these are the atruskians and the
atruskians are very similar to the
marinian Greeks and as you can see um
they are expanding throughout the
uh Italian peninsula. Now the thing
about empires is that eventually the
people become lazy, arrogant and stupid
and so what they do is they get people
to fight for them. So the Romans are
here and as you can see um this is the
borderlands and the entire area is
surrounded by great warriors. This is a
poor region and so they're always
fighting for resources. So the Romans
get recruited as mercenaries and over
time what will happen is that they will
start to emerge as the great power in
the Italian peninsula. And at this point
in history, this is really important.
They're surrounded by lots of different
people that are like them and they're
warlike. So they triumph because they
become the most warlike of everyone.
Okay. [snorts] Their entire society is
based on war. This is a truskin
civilization and um as you can see it is
very advanced. The Atrusian civilization
is heavily in contact with the Egyptians
um and the Greeks and as well as people
around them because they are ser fairing
people and this is the civilization that
will most heavily influence uh the
Romans. As you can see the atricians are
always at war as well and then as become
wealthier they will recruit the uh
Romans to fight for them. This is not a
great map, but this what this map shows
you is the gradual expansion of Rome.
So, at first, as you can see, it is
actually at the most disadvantaged
location because it's always it's
surrounded by enemies. Um, it is on flat
land and so it's not easily defensible
and it's not really by the coast and
therefore it's hard for it to trade. But
because it is in such a disbanded
position, it is forced to be the most
marshall, the most violent, the most
militaristic, the most aggressive. And
the culture evolves around that. And
slowly over time, they're able to
conquer the entire um Italian peninsula
and then expand uh to the Mediterranean.
Okay. So, this is another map that shows
you uh Rome and how it's going to expand
over time. The way it expands is through
military conquest and then by building
roads. And this is very impressive
because if you ever been to Italy, it is
very hilly. So there's a tremendous
effort to build roads. But once they
build the roads, they're able to
consolidate and navigate their empire.
[snorts] Um this is this is a map that
shows you the geography of um Italy. As
you can see, it's very mountainous. um
and there are that many rivers which
tells us it's very poor and because it's
very poor the people tend to be very
unified uh very aggressive and they have
a deep egotarianism because only by
working together can you ultimately
triumph over the other people okay so
there's a main characteristic about Rome
in the early days that you must remember
it is poor it is small
okay and it is uh unified so everyone
knows each other and so because of its
geographic characteristics
we emerge it concept of liberty.
All right? And it's concept of liberty
is obedience to the fathers to history
to culture because only by doing so can
you uh survive as a people. Now what's
interesting about this is it's a
different concept from the Greeks. The
Greeks believe that what liberty is is
the right to speak your mind in front of
others.
Um and as such the major difference
between the Greeks and the Romans is in
in Greece citizenship is passed on from
family to family but in Rome citizenship
can be earned. Okay? It's an open
citizenship system. Why? Because
if you just obey the fathers, the laws,
the customs, then you can be a Roman
citizen. And as such, what's going to
happen is that as Rome expands, it's
going to incorporate different people
into its culture. And as a result, Rome
has advantage that Athens and Sparta
doesn't have. Rome can always replenish
its soldiers. And as such, it can afford
to lose war after war after war. But as
it does so, it gets stronger and
stronger because it's learning with each
defeat. Okay? And that is the secret to
Rome's ultimate victory. The heart and
center of Roman society is the Senate.
This is where the um leading families
come together to dis to discuss the fate
of Rome. And at this time in history
when Rome is poor, this is not a problem
because everyone knows each other and
there's no real inequality. Therefore,
there can be no corruption. And so these
fathers, the senators are representing
the representing the best interests of
all Romans. But over time as Rome
becomes wealthier and wealthier this
becomes a huge problem because as Rome
develops more wealth guess who gets all
the wealth these guys. Okay. So we we'll
we'll we'll see this later as as that as
Rome gets wealthier Rome also becomes
much more corrupt.
All right. So the Greeks the fighting
system is the hoplets. The Romans use
something called the legions. Now there
are some major differences between these
two fighting techniques. Even though for
their time they are the most advanced.
As you can see uh the Greek hoplights
are heavily armored. Okay. And as such
each hoplet needs to buy his own armor
which means that hoplights tend to be um
small land owners. Okay. They have a bit
of wealth. The legioners can be poor
because it doesn't actually require that
much armor to be a legionnaire. Okay.
That's the first thing. Second thing is
that it actually takes a lot of training
to be a hoplight. You basically have to
spend years and years honing your skills
because you fight information. Uh the
legionnaire you don't you you don't need
that much training. Okay, you can
actually go straight into battle. The
third major difference is that as you
can see the hoplights they are using
heavy armor shields um and helmets. The
legionnaires are much lighter. The
reason why is the legionnaires were
developed in a developed to fight in a
mountainous region. So they need to be
able to climb to hike up mountains in in
formation whereas the Greeks are
fighting more on flat land. Okay. So
over time what will happen is the
legionnaers will overwhelm the hoplets.
[snorts]
Um this is a typical Roman peasant. He's
spending most of his time farming and
when it's required of him, he goes to
war. Okay? He's not a full-time soldier.
Um so um the Greeks and the Romans will
fight a series of wars. So as the Romans
are expanding, they go they go closer
and closer to the coast. And here are a
lot of Greek colonies. and the Greeks
are losing to the Romans. So they call
for help from the compatriots
um across the sea and a king named Pyrus
of Eperis he decides to take advantage
of this opportunity to go conquer Italy.
Okay. So he and Hoplights sail over to
Greece and they are destroying the
Romans. Battle after battle, uh, Pyrus
is defeating the Romans. And then he
finally says, "You know what? If I win
one more battle, I'm going to have no
more soldiers." Okay? And that shows you
the difference between Greek fighting
versus Roman fighting. Greek fighting
uses specialized forces that uh can win
over time, whereas the Romans can just
keep on replenishing their forces. Okay?
So the Romans don't actually win that
many battles, but they win most of their
wars.
>> [snorts]
>> Okay. Now, as the Romans are expanding,
they eventually reach the Mediterranean.
And so, now they start developing a navy
in order to trade with um other uh
nations like Egypt and Greece. This
comes in conflict with the
Carthaginians. And at this time, the
main power in the Mediterranean are the
Carthaginians. now and they will fight a
war that lasts decades, 100 years and
ultimately Rome will triumph and the
main reason why that Rome triumphs and
this really important for you guys to
understand is the main difference
between Carthage and Rome is Carthage is
rich, Rome is poor. Okay, why why what
does this matter? Because if you're
rich, what you can do is hire
mercenaries to fight the war for you.
And that's what Carthage does. But Rome
is poor. Therefore, they must use their
own citizens to fight the war. Okay? And
so over time, the citizens become much
tougher, much more unified. Whereas the
Carthaginians, they become more corrupt.
They be become much more decadent. And
because the Romans are more invested in
the war, they will fight to the end.
Whereas the Carthaginians are business
people. They're traders. Okay? They're
very known for um their sharp business
skills. And so they do they do a
costbenefit analysis be like you know
what this war is going to cost us more
than if we just surrender. Okay. So the
carters surrender the first Punic war
they s the second Punic war and the
third Punic war. Guess what happens?
They're going to be wed up by the
Romans. Okay. So that's what the Roman
mentality is. We fight you, we'll fight
you to the death and if we beat you, we
will kill every one of you. Okay? That's
just the Roman uh war mentality. And
that's why they ultimately triumph in
the end.
Okay, so this is another map that shows
you the conflict between the
Carthaginians and the Romans. This is a
second Punic War. Okay, so um Carthage
over here, it's expanded to Spain and
there are lots of silver mines in Spain.
Um
Rome right now it's still pretty small,
okay? But again, because the Romans are
dedicated towards war, that's that's the
only thing they know. That's the only
thing they're good at. Okay, they will
eventually triumph over the
Carthageians. We actually don't know
that much about the history of Rome.
Okay, but the most famous episode during
the Second Punic War is when a
Carthaginian general named Hannibal
Barka, okay, he's in Spain and he
decides he's going to go destroy Rome.
The way he does it is by crossing the
Alps. Okay, so these are out mountains.
And for the longest time, Bman thought
that this was a natural barrier. And
what what what Hammer Barker will do is
he will cross the Alps with his war
elephants and his army, land in
um Italy and start attacking Rome. And
in three decisive battles, Hannibal will
destroy the entire Roman army. Okay? he
will wipe out the entire Roman army. And
at this point in history, Rome needs to
surrender. Okay? So Hannibal sends an
envoy to the Senate and tells them, "I
destroyed every single one of your
soldiers. You have no more army.
Therefore, I am willing to talk peace
terms." And the Senate is like, "Screw
you. Come get us." Okay? And this marks
a turning point in Roman history. So
let's look over some of the major
events. This is Hannibal crossing the
Alps. Okay? one of the most famous
military feats in human history. Um,
this is the battle of Trivia, one of the
first major battles where even though
Hannibal is um under man and he's in
enemy territory, what he will do is he
will use a series of brilliant military
maneuvers to ambush uh his enemies.
Okay, so these are the Romans. As you
can see, what's going to happen is the
the um
Carthaginians, their horsemen lies in
the marsh and then they will sneak up
and destroy the Romans from the rear.
Okay, that's the first major battle.
This is the battle of Lake Tresamine.
And the same thing basically happens
where the Romans are crossing then the
then Hannibal ambushes them from the uh
hills. Okay, the second major battle and
this is [snorts] the most famous battle.
This is about called the battle of
Kaine. Okay, and this what we call a
double involvement strategy where what
will happen is that the two armies meet
and then uh Hannibal will send his
cavalry on the wings and then they will
envelop the Roman army and then they
will slaughter everyone. Okay, so Romans
lose between 50,000 to 100,000 men.
Their entire army is wiped out because
of this battle. Okay. So, uh this is the
first phase. Second phase is when the uh
cavalry starts to uh flank the uh Romans
and in the third phase um the soldiers
come in from behind and trap the Romans
and kill everyone. Okay. So, this is the
most famous battle in military history.
Now, there's a problem with this battle
which is this has never happened before
in human history. Remember before we
discussed the idea that in China, one of
the most um common military strategies
is behind the river strategy. Okay? So
you force your men to go to a river and
now the enemy is approaching them and
have no choice but to fight to the end
because otherwise they'll drown. Okay?
But if you can see this situation, it's
very similar. The Romans are in a very
similar situation where they where
they're being surrounded by enemies on
all sides, right? So at this time what
what should happen theoretically is they
become energized and the entire Roman
army goes and fights the Carthaginians
and defeats the Carthaginians. Okay, we
have we have examples of that. We don't
we don't have an example of in fact an
entire army in ancient times being
surrounded and being slaughtered by the
enemy. This is a very strange battle.
In fact, if you ask chat GBT which
battles have used double envelopment
strategy,
basically you have battle canine. Okay,
we have that. But the next one is 1940.
1940 in World War II. Now, the
difference of course is is that by the
time you hit the 1940s, you have machine
guns, you have tanks. So, if you start
an enemy, you can destroy your enemy.
But not in ancient times. Okay? In in
fact, the closest parallel that we have
is a battle of Marathon. But even his
but some historians suggest. Okay, so
we're not very so even historians
disagree whether or not the battle
marathon was actually double in
strategy. This makes no sense.
This battle strategy makes no sense from
a military p perspective.
Also,
we can't find the damn place.
You would think this is a huge battle.
50,000 100,000 women are dead. There'd
be a lot of bodies. We can't find a damn
place. Okay, look. There's no
archeological evidence to prove the
battle took place.
We we don't have any evidence. That's
kind of strange. Okay. Um yeah, but
maybe it's because of the weather or,
you know, we don't know. Okay.
All right, guys. So, um what's going on
here? Okay. So, on YouTube, someone
asked me, "How do we know what history
is true or not?" Okay. Now, you would
think the answer is you just ask
historians whether it's true or not. You
know the answer. The problem is that
every historian that you talk to tells
you the battle canal must be historical
fact. It must be even though we don't
have any evidence for it. So given that,
how can we
um understand or figure out if it's true
or not? Well, in this class, what I
teach you is a new historical framework
to understand history. Okay, so this is
predictive of history and we look we ask
ourselves does the battle of cannot fit
into a larger historical pattern. Okay,
second question we ask is does it make
sense according to game theory? And the
third question is does religion explain
the battle? Okay, and when we do this,
we use this framework to understand the
back canal our conclusion must be it
didn't happen. It was completely made
up. Okay, the back canal did not happen.
So why? Well, first of all, when we have
these great military generals like Kavar
Barka, they tend to become a king. Okay,
so think of Napoleon U or think of
Julius Caesar. Hannah Barker is the
first general that we have that
conquered all of Rome and decided I'm
sit back and like retire for the next 50
years. Okay, never happened before. Why
didn't he go back to Carthage and rec
and claim the kingship? Right? Okay,
that's the first problem. Second problem
is game theory. Okay.
So if you read Roman history, what they
would tell you is that Hannibal after
the battle of Canal, he was stuck in
Italy without resources. Then the
question is when he go to Carthage,
conquer the place and demand the
resource he needs to win against Rome.
Why is he sitting back? Okay. Also
remember this is a guy who crossed the
Alps on his own initiative. The cockian
told him, "Don't start a war with Rome,
Hannibal." And Hannibal's like, "Nah,
I'm going to go across our Alps. Thank
you very much." Okay. So this makes
absolutely no sense whatsoever.
And then from a religious perspective,
how can we explain what h why Hannibal
did what he did? And Roman historians
will tell you, "Oh, it's because his
father lost against Rome. He wanted
revenge for on behalf of his father."
That makes no sense, guys. Okay? Usually
when a Napoleon emerges, it's because he
thinks he's a son of God. Think think of
Napoleon. Think of Alexander the Great.
Think of Julius Caesar. Okay? They all
have a mess calling, a divine mission.
All right. So from this only conclusion
can be first of all battle did not
happen. There's no way it could have
happened. And second thing is you can
also say that Hannibal Bark Hannibal
Barka did not exist as per as a person.
All right. But then this leads us to a
really huge problem which is why would
the Romans just make this stuff up?
Why? Why would they say we fought this
battle and 100,000 of our men got killed
by this Carthage General Hannibal who
was smarter than us? Okay. Well, the
reason why is
this Carthage. Okay, that Carthage is at
this time in history about 200 BC the
most beautiful, the most prosperous, the
most culturous city in the world. And
what did Romans do?
They burned it to the ground and killed
everyone. Okay, that's the Roman way.
Now um
this is a siege of Carthage that lasted
many many years in the third punic war.
The Romans if they don't like you they
will come and kill every one of you.
Okay and that's what they did in
Carthage.
Now during this war a Greek named
Palibius okay Palibius uh was a hostage
of Rome and he became the official
historian of the Roman Empire. So this
is a guy who invented the battle of
Canaan. Why? To justify
the burning of Carthage, right? Because
the Romans are like, "Why did we kill
the Carthaginians?" Because that's what
we do, man. Okay? But Palibius is Greek
and he understands that, you know, if
Rome you're going to be an empire, you
need people on your side. You can't go
around just killing people. You need you
need to explain your actions. So, in
other words, Palibius
in order to justify the Roman Empire
create this entire history of the
psychopunic war that didn't really
happen. Okay? Because now it's like okay
well the Romans felt threatened by
Hannibal right Hannibal was going to
destroy them and so they all saw
Carthage as a threat and therefore they
had to destroy Carthage. Now it's much
more reasonable. Okay so Palibus
basically made the entire history of
Rome. The thing to remember about
history is that if you're a military
power you don't write history. Why?
Because you you're not capable of
reflection. You're not capable of deep
cultural production. Okay. So the Romans
won all these battles and got the Greeks
to write their history for them to just
justify
why they did what they did. Okay? Does
that make sense, guys? All right. So
again, I hate to say this, but basically
um all Roman history is complete
nonsense. All right? Um if you read
Roman history, just don't believe
anything you you read. Okay?
All right. So um let's look at the Roman
war machine because after the war
against Carthage, after Rome destroys
Carthage, Rome is the undisputed leader
of the Mediterranean. It's an empire
now, but it still keeps on fighting
these wars overseas for no particular
reason. Why? Because it has no choice in
the matter. This is the entire Roman war
machine. Okay? So
um because Rome is a poor poor place,
the only way that it can generate wealth
is by conquering other people. Okay? So
the nobility wants to go fight these
wars overseas so that they can capture
slaves. Why? Because they can get these
slaves then to work their estates. Okay?
So at this time in history, slaves are
the main resource that people are
fighting over. Okay? Now to fight these
wars, peasants are conscripted into the
military. But once they leave the land,
they need to feed the families, right?
So what do they do? They borrow money
with their land as collateral. Okay? But
over time, what happens is they can't
pay back the interest, right? They
default on the loan and then land
owners, nobility, seize the land. Then
what they do is they get the slaves that
they conquer to come work this land.
Right? Now the peasants have no choice
but to go to Rome to look for work
because they've lost their land. And the
Roman state gives them food. It's called
a grain do. Okay?
And so now the nobility wants to go
fight more wars. What they do is they
bribe the peasants to vote for more wars
and then the peasant can go and maybe
win some booty. Okay, because they have
no land. [snorts] And um so what what's
happening is that what the R woman war
machine is doing is creating slavery,
debt, corruption and inequality. Okay.
And over time what happens is that
wealth becomes more consolidated in
fewer hands which creates conflict
between the upper nobility and the lower
nobility. The optimates are are called
the upper nobility and the popular are
called the low nobility. Okay. So what's
the difference? Optimates just means the
best of the best. Okay. Why do I have so
much money? Because I'm better than you
are. In fact, my entire family is better
than you are.
Popular is where where we get the word
populist from. So this is lower nobility
people like Julius Caesar who take
advantage of the discontent in order to
launch their political careers and what
they do is they promise the peasants the
people u more opportunities okay to take
the wealth of the rich and give it more
to the poor. Okay so this is a conflict
that will arise in Rome after the end of
Carthage and this will last for
centuries until the very end of the
Roman Empire. Okay. The in other words,
the Roman war machine doesn't know how
to stop. Even even when it becomes an
empire, all this aggressive military
energy then translate translate into
civil war. Okay. So, the Romans aren't
killing other people, they're killing
each other.
All right. Um this is a question from a
YouTube um a viewer and uh
Ford asks why are wars good at
maintaining equilibrium. Okay, why is it
that uh wars help reduce a problem of
elite over production? Okay, and the
reason why is and and I I I know I know
it's hard for you guys to understand
this but wars are beneficial. All right.
So, let's go over the the the benefits
of war. Well, first of all, you create
social co cohesion, right? You're
fighting against another person. You
have to stand together. So, it creates a
dialectic, a hatred of the other, which
gives meaning and purpose to life. Okay?
Uh it creates social mobility. If you're
poor, you go fight a war, you get lucky,
you can become pretty wealthy. Uh wolf
destruction and generation. Okay? So,
you're destroying wealth, which allows
for more opportunities.
uh survive the fittest. So population
control. So basically the stronger
survive in war, the weak die off. Uh
high fertility rate because so many
people are dying. Mothers are forced to
have more and more children. Okay? They
don't have a choice in the matter. Um
innovate release of social tension. So
people don't like each other. They go
fight a war together and now they're
best friends. Um innovation, creativity,
entertainment for nobility. Okay.
Competition. Um, war is often just the
the nobility just enjoys wars because
it's like playing a chess game. Okay,
they're not the ones dying. Worst case
scenario, they become hostages, right?
All right. So again, what happens is
that after Carthage is destroyed, the
Romans turn against each other. Okay.
The first one that happens is something
called the social wars. Basically, it's
the um Roman allies who were told to
fight a war and return. They regret
citizenship. they were not grant grant
citizenship. So they rebelled against
the Roman state and this led to civil
war. Okay. But the problem is you're now
fighting the Roman army. So you're not
going to win. So eventually the Roman
state had to give in and give
citizenship to these uh people. Okay.
This is uh one of the most radical
turning points in Roman history. So um
right now there's massive inequality in
Rome. The nobility have all the land.
They have slaves to work the land. the
peasants are uh having problems feeding
themselves in the cities. Okay, so now
what do you do? So u this man is named
Tyberus Graas and he's a reformer and he
says basically here hey guys here's what
we're going to do. The rich have all
this land. We're not going to touch that
because we have to respect private
property but there's all this public
land that's not being used. It belongs
to women state. We have all these poor
people that want to work the land but
they have no land. So what we'll do is
this. We'll take public land that no
one's touching. Okay? No one's using
this stuff. Give it to the people to
work to generate more wealth for our
society. We have more tax revenue. The
people are happier. And yeah, and no one
gets hurt. Okay. Perfect. Perfect
solution, right? Because he proposed a
solution. The nobility
beat him to death. Okay. Not only did
they beat him to death, they beat his
brother to death as well.
Okay.
Oh my god.
>> Why do they do this? Because nobility is
how dare you steal OUR PUBLIC LAND FROM
US. OKAY. So nobility was like this
public land belongs to us man because we
are the state.
Screw the people.
Okay. All right. So of course this leads
to the rise of dictators. So there have
been different dictators who've um come
to power and they've tried to solve the
social conflict within Rome. The first
is Marius who promised reform but really
didn't deliver. Then you have Solo.
Okay. And Solo's solution was really
simple. Let's just kill all the
reformers. Pretty simple guys. Okay. Our
problem isn't the inequality. The
problem is you got too many people uh
who proposed reform. So he just killed
all the reformers. Okay. What? And then
after he killed the reformers retired.
One of these reformers who got away was
Julius Caesar. Okay. So Julius Caesar
because his family was very wealthy was
able to escape Solah and but he's a very
ambitious man. So now he's going to
build his political career based on the
discontent of the people.
And what he's going to do is that he's
going to um bribe his way into office so
that he can get a general ship to go
invade Gaul. Okay. So he goes to Gaul
which is in modern day France. He spends
many years there. Um what's he doing
there? Okay. Okay. Well, if you look at
official Roman history, what he's doing
there is he's trying to pacify the
people of Gaul. Okay. So he has these
like these series of mil military
campaigns in Gaul and it culminates in
uh so he's leading his soldiers into war
in Gaul and it culminates in something
called the battle of Alicia which one of
the most famous battles in history.
Basically what hap what's happening is
that um this is the very last battle of
um Caesar's G campaign. What he's done
is he's surrounded a village where his
enemies are. Okay? But his enemies send
word to all the gic tribes to come and
converge against the Romans. So what the
Romans do is they build fortifications
to block out the invaders. Okay? So
they're fighting wars on both fronts.
They're fighting in the inside against
the enemies trapped here. They're also
fighting against the enemies coming from
outside as well. And u Alicia is one of
the greatest battles in human history.
And again we have reason to think that
this didn't happen. Okay. So what was
Caesar doing in Gaul and why was he
starting all these wars? The answer is
really simple. Okay. There are three
reasons. The first is remember slaves
are the most valuable commodity at this
time. So what he's doing is he's
basically capturing slaves. He's going
and he's starting these wars in order to
capture slaves. Caesar said famously um
I killed a third of people go. I
enslaved a third of them and I left a
third alone. Okay, so he basically
committed genocide against the the
people of Gaul. And um what's important
to understand is he probably
exaggerated. He probably didn't kill a
third. Why? Because if he captures
slaves, a lot of this money has to go to
the Roman state. But if he kill if he
pretends to kill the GS but actually
enslaves them, then all the money goes
to him. Okay? So by enslaving people, he
became filthy rich. In fact, he became
the wealthiest man in Rome and he used
this money to bribe his his um friends
into office. Okay, so he became also the
most politically powerful individual in
Rome. That's the reason number one he
went why he went to go. Second is that
Caesar
um was trying to build a loyal army, a
private army that was loyal to him. And
so just because he was able to give
money to these soldiers, these soldiers
not only were loyal to him, but they
also develop a lot of fun experience
while in Gaul, right? So now Caesar has
the world's most powerful army. The
third reason why he went to go and this
most important is to create a myth of
himself as a great conqueror. Um all
these great politicians understand
people don't really understand the
difference between reality and fantasy.
In fact, they don't care what about the
difference. Okay, people will believe
what they want to believe. So, what what
Cu was doing was he was going to go and
then um he was getting people to go back
to Rome and announce all his victories.
Okay, we have reason to believe that a
lot of these victories were made up, but
it gave the impression among the Romans
that Caesar was this great conqueror.
Okay, so
think of this guy, right? What's he
doing?
He's trying to create an image of
himself as energetic, dynamic, verile.
Right.
Right. Does that make sense? Oh, and a
better example, of course, is this guy.
Okay. Right. Donald Trump. He spent a
lot of years in the World Wrestling um
Federation trying to portray himself as
macho, as energetic, as strong, right?
And then for over 10 years, he had the
most popular television show on TV
called The Apprentice, where he
pretended to be this savvy genius of a
business person, right? The Apprentice
and this is what really launched his
political career. All right? So, this is
all these great politicians understand.
If you really want to have a great
political career, you have to create a
myth of yourself as an entrepreneurial
military genius.
Okay. So, um after Gaul, the Roman
Senate basically gets really annoyed at
Caesar because they understand what he's
trying to do. He's trying to become king
of Rome. So, they basically try to
impeach him. Okay? They they want to put
him on trial. So Caesar basically
rebelss against them and this starts a
civil war and what's going to happen is
that Caesar is going to go conquer the
entire Roman Empire. Now um it's one man
and his army against the entire empire.
So he should have lost. The problem is
that the Ottomates are really stupid,
arrogant and lazy. Okay, there's so um
Pompei, General Pompei is fighting for
the Ottomans and he's going against
Caesar and Pompe strategy it's really
simple. Okay, Caesar has control over
Italy. There's a problem though. Italy
is poor. It does not have produce enough
food. So all we have to do is lay siege
to Italy and if we start war is over.
That's all we have to do, right? We
don't have to fight Caesar. Just lay
siege to Italy.
Um the people starve, the people rebel
against Caesar and then Caesar loses the
war. [snorts] The problem though is the
optimist afraid that if Pompei won the
war, then they would make Pompei king,
right? So what the optimist wanted to do
was force Pompei and Juju Caesar into a
battle and have and kill both. Okay?
They wanted to destroy both. And this
led to something called a battle of
Farcus. Remember at this time Caesar
needs to go fight Pompei. But Pompei
doesn't have actually to fight Caesar
but the ultimates force him to fight in
a battle called farceless. Okay. And in
this battle because Caesar has a loyal
army
they defeat Pompei even though Pompe has
more soldiers. Okay. And then what um
Caesar will do is then go conquer the
entire Roman Empire and he makes himself
dictator of Rome. And this of course
leads to his assassination. Why is he
assassinated? because the Romans are
afraid that he'll make himself king and
he will abolish a debt of the people and
he will reappropriate the land and give
it to the people. Okay? He'll basically
make himself king by making Rome a much
more equal and egalitarian place. And so
they killed him. And this led to more
civil war um in which Octavius Caesar,
Augustus Caesar will will be triumphant
because he will inherit Julius Caesar's
army. And at the battle of Actium in 31
BC, he would destroy Mark Anthony and
Cleopatra, making himself the supreme
ruler
of the Roman Empire. Okay? And he's
really considered the first Roman
emperor. But what's really important for
us to understand is
at this point in history um the problems
of Rome don't really go away. He is
emperor and during his time things are
stable. But after he dies, the Roman
Empire goes back into civil war and he
keeps and it does not stop fighting
civil war until its very collapse. Okay.
What makes him um emperor is the fact
that he will take Egypt and turn into
his private property and he will use the
wealth of Egypt to fund the army. So all
the soldiers are now loyal to him
individually as opposed to the Roman
state. Okay. Now, August Augustus
Caesar, he was not a military genius,
but he he appreciated that if the Roman
people were to survive, they needed a
culture as distinct and as powerful as
Greek culture. At this time in history,
the Greeks um were culturally dominant.
And he's he was afraid that over time,
all Romans would just become Greeks. So
he needed to create a culture that was
distinct from the Greeks but also
considered much more powerful than the
Greeks. Okay. So that was his main major
contribution to the Roman Empire. So
what he does is he takes the work of Po
Palibius. Remember Pibius is the main uh
architect of the history of Roman Empire
and he tells Libby to basically rewrite
the history but from a Roman lens as
opposed to a Greek lens. Okay. So this
is a very really famous book written by
Libby uh sponsored by Octavius Caesar.
Okay. So we're we're going to read a bit
of it to understand the Roman mentality.
Okay. All right.
All right. So um what's happening is
this. The book starts with the founding
of Rome. And in the Roman tradition,
what's going to happen is um the Romans
are descendants of Troy. Remember Troy
and Aliad was destroyed by the Greeks.
How did the Greeks destroy Troy? Through
trickery, through deception, right? The
Trojan horse. And then what will happen
is the Greeks flood into the city and
kill everyone. But there's a Trojan
general named Inas and his wife Kisha.
What he will what they will do is they
will escape. Okay. Um, Troy, sorry. In
order to found Rome. Now, Kishia is the
wife and what she what she will do is as
they leaving Troy, she will kill herself
in order to allow Inas to escape fully.
Okay. So, in the Roman tradition, all
that matters is the father. Okay. So,
you can see the father can't walk. So,
Inas has to um shoulder him to the ship.
And woman don't matter at all. Okay?
That's the Roman tradition.
All right. Um, so what happens next is
Rome is founded by twins, uh, Ramlas and
Remis, and they
will, um, fight for the kingship of
Rome. Okay. So, can you read the story
of Ramis and Remis?
>> Remis is said to have been the first to
receive an omen. Six vultures appeared
to him. The augury had just been
announced to Rmulus when double the
number appeared to him. Each was saluted
as king by his own party. The one side
based their claim on the priority of the
appearance, the other on the number of
the birds, then followed an angry
altercation.
Heated passions led to bloodshed. In
their turmoil, Rez was killed. The more
common report is that Remis
contemptuously jumped over the newly
raised walls and was forth killed by the
enraged Romulus who exclaimed, "So shall
it be henceforth with everyone who
leaves over my walls." Romulus thus
became sole ruler and the city was
called after him its founder.
>> So Ramos and Remis are twins. Okay, they
love each other and um Rome was founded
on violence. Okay, that's the very
nature of Rome, a city based on
violence.
This story, if you remember,
um, sorry. Okay, so so now Rome founds a
city called Rome and he invites anyone
to join him and over time they become
much more powerful and they threaten
their neighboring states and they cannot
and these states cannot defeat Rome in
war. So what they decide is, you know
what,
we can't beat the Romans in battle, but
if our daughters don't marry into them,
they'll be dead after one generation.
They they won't have any children. Okay?
So there's this compact among the
nations of Italy not to marry into Rome.
So Romans discover this and they hatch
this plan. What they're going to do is
they're going to have this major
festival and they're going to invite all
the families to come to this festival
and then um they will kidnap a woman and
rape them. Okay, that's the plan. Okay.
They were invited to accept hospitality
at the different houses. And after
examining the situation of
[clears throat] the city, its walls, and
the large number of dwelling houses
included, they were astonished at the
rapidity with which the Roman state had
grown. When the hour for the games had
come and their eyes and minds were alike
raveted on the spectacle before them,
the preconert the preconer signal was
[clears throat] given and the Roman
youth dashed in all directions to carry
off the maidens who were present. The
larger part were carried off indiscrim
indiscriminately.
But some particular beautiful girls who
had been marked out of the leading
patricians were carried to their houses
by plebeians told off the tad off for
the task. Alarm and concernation
broke up the games and the parents of
the maidens fled, distracted with grief,
uttering bitter reproaches on the
violators of the laws of hospitality and
appealing to the god who to whose solemn
games they had come only to be the
victims of impious perity. Okay. So,
this is actually a very serious crime
because when you invite people into your
house, there are these laws that um you
must show uh hospitality
to your guests otherwise you will offend
the gods themselves because it's
possible the person you invite into your
house is a god himself. Okay. So, what
the Romans did was outrageous. [snorts]
Okay.
The abduct maidens were quite as
despondent and indignant. Rmulus,
however, went round in person and
pointed out to them that it was all
owing to the pride of their parents in
denying rights of inner marriage to
their neighbors. They would live in
honorable wedlock and share all their
property and civil rights and dearest of
all to human nature would be the mothers
of free men. He begged them to lay aside
their feelings of resentment and give
their affections to whose to those whom
fortune had made masters of their
persons and injury had often led to
reconcilation and love. They would find
their husbands all the more affectionate
because each would do his utmost so far
as in him lay to make up for the loss of
parents and country. These arguments
were reinforced by endearments of the h
other husbands who excused their conduct
by pleading the irresistible force of
their passion. A plea effective beyond
all other and appealing to a woman's
nature.
>> Okay. So the are pretty disgusting.
Okay. They rape a woman said it's your
fault or it's your parents' fault. And I
really couldn't control myself. So sorry
man, but I'll be nice to you. Okay.
[clears throat]
Yep. All right. So this this is um a
pretty um memorable event in Roman
history. It's called the rape of the
Sabian woman. Okay. And these are
different artworks deping depicting the
event.
Okay. Um so the fathers are obviously
pissed about about this. Okay. So a huge
army is created to rescue the woman
back. And now these these Roman soldiers
are now facing this huge army. And when
this happens as about the the clash,
these women who are raped, they come
screaming forward in the middle and say,
"Stop. Stop. Stop. You're you're my
husband. You're my father. We don't want
you to fight." Okay. Uh can you read,
please?
Then it was that the Sabian women, whose
wrongs had led to the war, throwing off
all womenish fears in their distress,
went boldly into the midst of the flying
missiles with de
>> deceived
>> deceived hair and red [snorts] garment,
running across the space between the two
armies. They tried to stop any further
fighting and calm the excited passions
by appealing to their fathers in the one
army and their husbands in the other not
to bring upon themselves a curse by
staining their hands with the blood of a
father-in-law or son-in-law nor upon
their posterity the taint of paris
parasid
>> parasite
>> parasite if they cried you are wary of
these ties of kindred these marriage
bonds then turn your anger upon us it It
is we who are the cause of the war. It
is we It was we who had wounded and
slain our husbands and fathers. Better
for us to perish rather than live
without one or the other of few as
widows or as orphans. The armies and
their leaders were alike moved by this
appeal. There was a sudden hush and
silence. Then the generals advanced to
arrange the terms of a treaty. It was
not only peace that was made. The two
nations were united into one state. the
royal powers was shared between them and
the seat of government for both nations
was Rome.
>> Okay, so this could possibly happen,
right? So these women are abducted, the
fathers try to rescue them and then the
women say, "Hey, it was our fault. Like
let's just all be one big family." Okay,
so this this is one of the founding
myths of Rome. And I and I keep on
saying this, but like just take all
Roman history and just like throw it in
the garbage, okay? Because it's it's
basically all made up.
All right. So, um Rome built becomes
more and more powerful and now they have
a king. Okay. But over time, their king
becomes very corrupt. Uh their king is
superbut. Superb bus just means
arrogant. And his son falls in love with
a noble woman named Lucricia. But
Lucricia is already married to a man
named uh Kentinius. And so this the
prince decides to go, you know, rape
her. [laughter]
Okay. And yeah. Okay.
>> They found Lucriccia sitting in her room
prostrate with grief. As they entered,
she burst into tears and to her
husband's inquiry whether all was well,
replied, "No, what can be well with a
woman when her honor is lost? The marks
of a stranger collad colinus caladeness
are in your bed. But it is only the body
that have been violated. The soul is
pure. Death shall bear witness to that.
But pledge me your solemn word that the
adulter shall not go unpunished. It is
sexist harquin who coming as an enemy
instead of a guest. Forced from me last
night by brutal violence a pleasure
fatal to me and if you're a man fatal to
him. They all successively pledged their
word and tried to console the distracted
women by turning the guilt from the
victim of the outrage to the perpetrator
and urging that it is the mind that
sins, not the body. And
where there has been no consent, there
is no guilt. It is for you, she said, to
see that he gets in deserts. [snorts]
Although I equip myself to the sin, I do
not free myself from the penalty. No
untasted woman shall henceforth live and
plead Lucricia's example. She had a
knife concealed in her dress which she
plunged into her heart and fell dying on
the floor. Her father and husband raised
the death cry.
>> Okay, so she is raped by the prince and
um her husband and best friend uh the
best friend is Lucius Brhus. Okay, they
try to console her and they know she's
distraught. Okay, but but Lucia is like,
"No, I don't be consoled. I want I want
revenge." We're Romans, man. We fight to
the bitter end. If you hit me, I go kill
you. If you kill me, I go kill the
entire family. Okay? And that's just a
Roman way. So what happens is like
Brutus, Lucius Brhes, he leads a revolt
against the king and the king is forced
out of Rome and um now Rome is a
republic. It's it's now run by the
nobility.
And a lot of people aren't happy with
this system because before if you're
good friends with a king, you can do
whatever you want. But now you have to
follow the laws of Rome. And so people
conspire against the new um republic.
And a couple of the conspirators include
two of Lucius Buddhist sons. Okay, his
two sons. and the conspirators is found
out and all the conspirators are
arrested and they're condemned to death.
Lucius Buddhist
decides he's going to put his own sons
to death. So he orders and organizes the
assa the execution of his two sons.
Okay. Their punishment created a great
sensation owing to the fact that the
cons c consular office imposed upon a
father the duty of inflicting punishment
on his own children. He who ought not to
have witnessed it was destined to be the
one to see it do duly carried out.
Youths belonging to the noblest families
were standing tied to the post but all
eyes were turned to the consil's
children. The others were unnoticed. Men
did not grieve more for their punishment
than for their crime which had incurred
it. That they should have conceived the
idea in that in that
in that year above all of betraying to
one who had been a ruthless tyrant and
was now an exile and an enemy. a newly
liberated country. Their father who had
liberated it. The consil ship which had
originated in the junian hoon junian
house, the senate, the plebs, all the
Rome possessed of human or divine. The
consils took their seats. The listenitor
uh victors were told off to inflict the
penalty. They scourged their bearbacks
with rods and then beheaded them. During
the whole time, the father's countenance
betrayed his feelings, but the father's
stern resolution
was still more apparent as he
superintended the public execution.
>> So, you're a father, right? And these
are your two sons. You love your two
sons more than anything else in the
world. You are forced by the law to
execute your two sons. Okay. Now, most
fathers would be like, you know what?
I'm going to call in sick. I'm I'm going
to go home and sleep until my sons are
are dead. Lucas Buddhist is like, "No,
I'm going to actually watch my two sons
get killed." Not only that, but I'm
going to organize their execution. Okay?
And we can imagine, okay, this is Lucas
Buddhist, and he has to watch as his
sons are being beheaded right before
him, and he's the one ordering their
their um execution. As you can see,
people are disgusted. They have to look
away. And people are looking at his
expression and you can see the emotional
turmoil in his face, right? There's
hatred, there's disgust, there's
contempt, there's guilt. He hates
himself, right? He hates his son, but he
hates himself even more. There's all
this
um crazy energy, hateful energy that's
being unleashed.
The Roman way is take all this energy
and turn it against your enemy. Okay,
that's a secret of the Roman military to
create a society so hateful, so angry,
so vicious that people have all this
demonic energy in them that they can now
use against your enemy. Okay, so let's
see what happens. What's going to happen
now is
the king decides to attack Rome because
this conspira conspiracy has failed,
right? What Lucius Buddhist is going to
do is ride out and meet the army head
on. Okay, can you read please?
>> So two armies from these cities followed
Tarun to recover his crown and cha
chastised the Romans. When they had
entered the Roman territory, the
consoles advanced against them. Val
Valyrias with the infant infantry and
Fallon's information uh formation.
Brutus recon
>> reconing
>> reconetrying in advance with the
cavalry. Similarly, the enemy's calvary
was in front of his main body, Areronus
Tarkin, the king's son in command. The
king himself followed with the
legionnaires. Whilst still at a
distance, Aaron distinguished the
console by his escort of list licers as
they drew nearer. He clearly recognized
Brutes by his features and in a
transport of rage exclaimed, "That is
the man who drove us from our country.
See him proudly advancing adorned with
our insignia. Ye God, Avengers of kings,
aid me." With these words he dug spurs
into his horse and rode straight at the
console. Brutus saw that he was making
for him. It was a point of honor in
those days for the leaders to engage in
single combat. So he eagerly accepted
the challenge and they charged with such
fury, neither of them thinking of
protecting himself. If only he could
wound his foe that each drove his spear
at the same moment through the other's
shield and they fell dying from their
horses with their spears sticking in
them.
>> Okay, so you see what happened. Okay, so
Prudence is traumatized by the execution
of his two sons. There is now a void in
his heart. There is now a tear in his
heart. Right? But this tear is
unleashing all this energy that he can
now use against his enemy. Okay, that is
a secret. Trauma is a drug. The Roman
ways use trauma as as a drug to empower
you against your enemies.
Okay. [snorts]
All right. So um the problem though is
that um the Roman army is much smaller
than the king's army. So Romans are
forced back into their city. They have
to hide behind their walls and they're
under siege.
And there's a Roman noble man named
Mousius. And Mousius decides
to offer a proposal to the Senate. He
says to the Senate, "Listen, we're never
going to beat this king's army. what
what I can do is I can sneak into his
camp and assassinate the king. And so
the Senate is like, "Sure." So Mushi
swims across the Tyber and he sneaks in
into an enemy camp and he sees it's
payday. Okay. So So there's two men uh
the king and secretary giving out cash,
giving out money to the soldiers, and
they they look the same, they dress the
same, and Musas doesn't know which is
which. And at this point, he should be
like, "You know what? I'll come back
another day and figure out who's the
king." But now he's like, "You know
what? It's 50/50. You know, it's a coin
flip." So he takes his dagger and he
stabs the guy and it turns out to be the
secretary.
And he's arrested, okay? And he appears
before the king and he and the king says
to him, "You tell me the truth or I will
burn you in this fire."
And then Mushia says, "Okay, the truth
is this. I am one of hundreds of young
Roman men who have sworn to come and
kill you. One of us will succeed. I
failed today, but tomorrow someone else
will come. And if you fail, someone else
will come as well. And [snorts] then um
the king says, "Are you telling the
truth? If you are not telling the truth,
I will burn you alive." And then Mushius
is you know what? He takes his hand.
Okay, he takes his hand and he puts in a
fire and his hand is being burned. Okay.
He's just like
the king is freaked out. He's like, "You
Romans are the craziest bastards. You
guys are demonic. I'm out of here."
Okay. Though the war is over. All right.
All right. Can you read, please?
>> Here alone and help us and the utmost
peril. He was still able to inspire more
fear than he felt. I am a citizen of
Rome, he said. Men call me se
>> mucous
>> mucus. As an enemy I wish to kill an
enemy and I have as much courage to meet
death as I had to inflict it. It is the
Roman nature to act bravely and to
suffer bravely. I'm not alone in having
made this resolve against you. Behind me
there is a long list of those who aspire
to the same distinction. If then it is
your pleasure make make up your mind for
a struggle in which you will every hour
have to fight for your life and find an
armed foe on the threshold of your royal
tent. This is the war which we the youth
of Rome declared against you. We have
you have no sir ranks, no pitch battle
to fear. the matter will be settled
between you alone and each one of us
singly the king furious with anger and
at the same time terrified at the
unknown danger threatened that if he did
not promptly explain the nature of the
plot which he was darkly
hinting at he should be roasted alive oo
mucus cried and learned how lightly
those regards their bodies who have some
great glory in view then he plunged his
right hand into a fire burning on the
altar. Whilst he kept it roasting there
as if he were devoid of all sensation,
the king astounded at his pre
>> international conduct sprang from his
seat and ordered the youth to be removed
from the altar. Go, he said, you have
been a worse enemy to yourself than to
me. I would invoke blessings on your
courage if it were displayed on behalf
of my country as it is. I send you away
exempt from all rights of war unheers
and safe. The amuseiest reciprocating as
it were this generous treatment said
since you honor courage know that what
you could not gain by threats you have
obtained by kindness. 300 of us the
foremost amongst the Roman youth have
sworn to attack you in this way. The lot
felt to me first. The rest in the order
of their lot will come each in his turn
till fortune shall give us a favorable
chance against you.
>> Okay. So the Romans are crazy. Okay.
They are demonic. All right. So um none
of this is true. Okay. It can't possibly
be true. You can't put your hand in a
fire and like not feel anything. Okay.
But where this is coming from is from
the uh protoindo-uropean myth. Remember
when we discussed the steps people they
had of mythology. Okay. So what what the
Romans are doing is they're taking this
mythology and they are adapting it to
their own history. Okay? So everything
that we've read is not true but the
Romans thought it was true. Okay? And
remember people don't can cannot
differentiate between fantasy and
reality. So as long as you think as long
as you believe it is true then
um it's true. Okay. And this is how
Romans behave. So um um yeah. So the
story of Lucius Buddhist kicking out uh
the Tarkkins
um is the story of the third man
stealing the cattle. Okay. So basically
stealing a throne from Tarquin and the
story of the man sacrificing his twin is
story of Romulus and Remis. Okay. All
right. [snorts]
All right. So now we get to the most
famous of all um Roman ethics called the
Iniad. And so at this time again um
Augustus Caesar has a problem in that
everyone acknowledges the Greek culture
be superior. Why? Because of Homer.
Okay, because of the Iliad. Remember we
read the Iliad and we remember how uh
the Iliad ends with an act of love and
forgiveness and compassion, right? Um,
Achilles feels guilt for for what he's
done for killing Petetro. He takes out
this rage on Hector, right? Which is a
very which is a Roman way. And then
Prime comes and forgives Achilles by
kissing his hand. And this um allows
Achilles to escape his guilt and they uh
forgive each other. And in the face of
Pryam, Achilles sees his father. In the
face of Achilles, Pry sees Hector. And
so they hug and they uh weep together.
Okay. And this idea of love as a
unifying force of the universe becomes
the basis of Greek culture and and of
Greek civilization. The Romans don't
like this for them. If you're a culture
based on hate, love is the greatest
enemy. Okay. So what is going to happen
is Augusta Caesar is going to ask a poet
named Virgil to rewrite this story in a
way that puts hate at the center of the
universe and not love. Okay. All right.
All right. So this is the Iniad by
Virgil. Considered one of the greatest
books in human history. It is a complete
piece of crap. Okay. It's propaganda.
All right. When you read it, you you see
how terrible it is. And uh basically
Virgil who was the most famous poet in
the Roman Empire at this time he's being
ordered by Augustus Caesar to write the
INAD and they write it together
basically basically with each draft
Virgil has to read it to August of
Caesar and then August Caesar tells him
how to rework it so it captures the
Roman spirit.
When Virgil was um about to die he asked
for the for the book to be burned. Okay.
because he as a poet understands that if
you are using the gift of God, poet use
the gift of God to promote hatred, then
you're going to burn in hell, man. Okay.
Um, so he asked to for this book to be
burned, but August Caesar, no, no, I
like it the way it is. Okay. So, this is
a rewriting of the Iliad. What's going
to happen is this.
The Greeks have broken into Troy and
they're killing everyone. Okay? And the
son of Achilles
uh
named Pyrus is killing the sons of
Pryam. And Pry faces uh Pyrus and he
tells Pyrus, "You're the son of
Achilles. Achilles was a noble person.
Have you no mercy?" And then like no.
And then he kills pirate. Pry. Okay. All
right. So can you read please?
>> Suddenly look a son a son of Pry
>> Pry. My bad. Pry polites just escaped
from slaughters as pyrus hands comes
racing in through spears through enemy
fighters fleeing down the long arcades
and deserted hallways badly wounded
pirates hot on his heels. A weapon
poised for the kill about to seize him
about to run him through and pressing
pressing home as polites reaches his
parents and collapses vomiting out his
life bloodl before their eyes. Okay, so
this is very similar to the death of
Hector, right? So remember Achilles
kills Hector and Prime witnesses it,
right? [snorts] And um something is
happening here where Polites is being
killed in front of Prime. So again, it's
a rewriting of the Iliad. Keep on going
>> at that Prime trapped in the grip of
death, not holding back, not checking
his words, his rage, you he cries, and
you and your vicious crimes. If any
power on high recoils at such an
outrage, let the gods repay you for all
your reckless work. Grant you the
thanks, the rich reward you've earned.
You've made me see my son's death with
my own eyes. Def def defiled a father's
sight with a son's lifeblood. You say
you're Achilles son. You lie. Achilles
never treated enemy pri so. No, he
honored he honored as suppliance right.
He blushed to betray my trust. He
restored my Hector's bloodless corpse
for burial. Sent me safely home to the
land I rule.
>> Okay, so this is the end of the Iliad.
Okay, so he's reminding everyone the
Iliad is a story about love,
forgiveness, compassion. Okay.
>> With that and with all his might, the
old man fling his spear, but too
important how to pierce. It merely
graced Fire's brazen shield that blocks
its way and clings there, dangling limp
from the boss, all for nothing. Pyrus
shouts back, "Well, then down you go. A
messenger to my father,
Pelia's son. Tell him about my vicious
work. How neo
Neoptoamus.
>> Neopalamus degrades his father's name.
Don't you forget now die. That said, he
dragged the old man straight to the
altar, quaking, slithering on through
slicks of his son's blood, and twisting
Pry's hair in his left hand. His right
hand sweeping forth his sword, a flash
of steel, he buries it hill deep in the
king's flank. Such was the fate of
Piriam. His death, his slot on earth
with Choi blazing before his eyes, her
ramparts down. The monarch who once had
ruled in all his glory the many land of
Asia, Asia's many tribes. A powerful
trunk is lying on the shore, the head
wrenched from the shoulders, a corpse
without a name.
>> Okay, so all Roman school children have
to memorize this poetry. And obviously
if you are a Roman school child and you
know that pry is from your ancestors you
have a deep hatred of the Greeks. Okay.
So the entire purpose of the Iniad is to
create hatred of the Greeks in order to
create a Roman identity.
All [snorts] right. So again the Greeks
were the greatest civilization we ever
had. Why? Because they were a
civilization based on reflection on
debate on openness. This is um a modern
reenactment of the play the Trojan
woman. Okay, this is a play by Eupites
that discusses what happens to the
children woman after Troy falls. They
become enslaved. The children are
killed. And so the Greeks when they
watch this play, they have to watch
their own darkness. They have to see for
themselves their own heart of darkness.
It causes tremendous empathy for their
enemies. Okay, this is the very idea of
civilization. And what do the Romans do?
They do this. Okay, gladiators. They
watch lions eat people. They watch men
kill each other. Okay, that's the Roman
way. The Greeks want to understand and
feel empathy for other people. The
Romans just want to kill other people.
All right. [snorts]
Um and in America today we have a very
similar Roman culture as well. This is
American football of course and um it is
pretty violent. Okay. It is pretty
barbaric.
All right. The Greeks for fun what the
elite do is they organize dinner parties
called symposia. Symposium. Um and in
the symposium what happens is that
people come together [snorts] and they
have conversations about love about
poetry about life. They will drink wine
but the wine is watered down. Okay. So
they can keep on drinking for a long
long time. The entire argument is just
to have a conversation.
All right.
>> All right. And so this is the idea of
the symposium.
Okay. This is a famous painting of
Alabades
coming in and having discussion with
everyone. So in Athenian culture, what's
important is to be a great speaker to be
intelligent to engage people in debate
and conversation and philosophy. Okay.
And what do the Romans do instead? Um
they get drunk and they throw up and
they have orgies. Okay. So the R woman
what women super fun is they have these
huge feasts these huge banquetss and
what they will do is they will go on the
food in the first course they go outside
and throw up. Okay they will throw up
the food so they can they can join the
second course they will w down the food
and then go and throw up again. Okay and
guys this is while people on the streets
starving to death. Okay.
>> Okay. This is u the Roman way. Okay. So
this is um the feast. This is almost a
reenactment of the rape of Sabian woman,
right? So they take um these myths. So
uh the death of Lucricia uh Mus burning
his hand, the rape of the Sabbian woman
and they use it as entertainment for the
societies. Okay. So this this is really
the beginning of secret societies,
right? All right. So what secret
societies do is they will take these
myths and reenact them out in order to
build sol um solidarity and trust and
cohesion among the secret members.
Um this is a picture of Nero just
getting drunk having a lot of sex. Okay.
So it's pretty it's it's pretty
pointless existence.
And of course in America you have this
um I don't understand why is it that
people think it's fun to do drugs get
get drunk and then go party all night.
Okay. But u apparently it's it's
supposed to be a lot of fun. Okay. All
right. So that is Roman culture. So Rome
becomes the dominant empire at this time
and it is an empire based on hatred
and it seems life is hopeless and so
what will happen is the universe will
send a messenger to remind people
there's still hope because there's God
in you and this person's name is
>> Jesus right so we'll discuss Jesus next
class okay so Jesus's response to the
Roman Empire so I'll I'll take some
quick questions
um from YouTube and then and then we'll
end the class. Okay. All right. So,
what does it mean to be a great man?
Okay. So, I say that love is unifying
force of the universe.
But then you have these great men who
come and conquer people. So, which is
which? Okay. Um so
um
in my in my understanding of things port
prophets are the greatest men. Okay.
People like Zorustra,
uh Homer, Jesus,
uh these are the the Yahweh in the
Bible. These are the great individuals
of human history issue because they
represent the truth. Okay? They are
messengers of the Monad. And then you
have people like Julius Caesar, Alexand
the Great, Napoleon who do a lot of
conquering. Okay. Um, and they have been
identified as great men of history. But
I think it's really Homer and Dante and
Plato who are the greatest people
because they create civilizations based
on their ideas. They actually change the
course of human history based on on
their ideas. Whereas people like
Napoleon, Julius Caesar, Exen the Great,
they're more like a culmination of the
trajectory of human history. Okay? If
that makes any sense. All right. Uh
let's move on.
All right. Um yeah, so the great head.
So what did the Iliad mean to the great?
Okay. So um to understand this idea,
think of a play. Okay, we all want to
put on a play. We all know a script, but
we need an actor to play a certain
character and then we're like, you know
what, Azen the Great plays Achilles.
Okay, so it's expected that a great will
behave the way of Achilles in the Iliad.
How did Achilles behave? Achilles saw
himself as a young romantic hero. He was
going to die in the beaches of Troy in
order to achieve eternal glory. Okay,
that's why Ezin the Great could not stop
fighting the war. In every battle, he
was leading the charge because he wanted
to die in battle. He wanted to be
Achilles. Only by dying in battle could
he achieve the fame of Achilles. Okay.
So, um he was acting out the play.
What's what's important is that he
himself saw himself as the reincarnation
of Achilles and everyone else saw him as
also the uh personification of Achilles
as well. Okay. So that's how this works.
[snorts] All right.
Um this person asks why is it that
Denmark, Norway, these Scandinavian
countries are so different from other
countries? Okay. Well, first of all,
they're small. Okay. They're really
small countries, millions of people.
Everyone knows each other. If you go to
Denmark, everyone knows the prime
minister of Denmark. Maybe she was their
neighbor or their friend. If they don't
know the prime minister, then they know
a friend who know who knows the prime
minister. So, it's a really small place.
Okay, that builds cohesion. That's
number one. Number two is guys, Denmark,
Norway are really cold places. That
means that people spend a lot of time
indoors together talking and becoming
friends. Okay? And also because it's so
cold, they have to work together. The
third factor is these countries are
surrounded by lots of dangerous enemies.
Germany, Russia,
um Sweden. Okay. And as such, they learn
that it's really important to stick
together and to work together.
Now what's interesting is that if you go
to a place like Holland, you go and you
think it's very egalitarian. But what's
really interesting is that it's actually
one of the most unequal places on earth
because the aristocrats have a lot of
money. But the but the problem is the
difference is like the aristocrats
understand like if the people are happy
they're more safe. Okay. So the
aristocrats will actually uh u promote
and support the welfare state because of
social cohesion. Okay.
All right. Um, a couple questions. Um,
so we are moving to the age of digital
technology, artificial intelligence.
Does it mean that empires will change
over time? Um, okay. This is something
that I will discuss towards the end of
the semester to the end of this course.
And it's a really interesting idea where
okay, you're an empire. you're lazy,
arrogant, and stupid. But maybe with
artificial intelligence, you have more
control over people. And in theory,
that's true. Okay? Once you have the AI
system, more you you'll be able to
control people better. But f but you
have to first build the AI system. And
that takes a lot of effort and energy.
And if you're in d empire like America,
you don't have the energy to build this
AI system. Okay. What you do have is a
lot of um desire and motivation to
create an AI scam. Okay, so chatbt is a
scam guys. It's not really doing
anything. But you can actually take this
technology and create like a matrix to
enslave people psychologically,
mentally. Okay, we'll discuss discuss
this towards the end of the semester. We
call this transhumanism. All right.
All right. Um
Okay. Okay, so Athenians and Spartans
were didn't want to destroy each other,
but that led to the rise of Macedonia.
How did that happen? The answer is
because they didn't care. Okay, do you
understand? They're the empire. So they
think they're invincible. If an empire
believed that a challenge challenge
could could arise, they would never ever
fall, guys. If an empire recognized that
it could fall one day, it would never
ever fall. It's because of hubris.
Because it's so arrogant, lazy, and
stupid that it falls. Okay? So it's
impossible for either Athens or or
Sparta to imagine that Macedonia would
one day overtake them.
All right. Um
last question is about secret societies.
Um how do secret societies work? All
right. So this is something that we will
discuss towards the end of the course.
Okay. But why is it that secret
societies are so powerful? All right. To
understand this, let's just do a thought
experiment. All right. So imagine this.
There's four groups of 100 people each,
okay? And there's this huge mountain,
the Himalayas. And the task is to get
get everyone to the top as soon as
possible. Okay? As quickly as possible.
There are four teams. Okay? Team one is
like you guys can do whatever you want.
Okay? We don't care. Team two is like if
everyone gets to the top, you get a
million dollars each, right? Team three
is one of the team members has a child
who's going to die unless you get to the
top because at the top is this magic
doctor who can save your son. Okay,
that's team three. Team four is there
are these demons that are chasing you
and they will you won't be able to
sleep. You won't be able to live in
peace if you don't stop running from
these demons. Okay, so guess what? Team
one, team two, team three, team four.
Who wins? Team four, obviously, right?
Not secret societies. Secret societies
create so much trauma. They create so
much guilt and hatred and contempt that
they're forced to keep on moving and
running. Okay, that's the Roman way,
guys. Okay, remember loses Brutus. He
killed his own two sons. What do you do
after that? Well, you have to go kill
someone else. Okay, and then after you
kill him, what do you do? You go kill
someone else. And you keep on going
because the guilt of killing your own
two sons, it's too much to bear. If you
just stop and you rest, your sons will
appear before you as ghost and like
they'll be like, "Dad, why did you kill
us? What did we do? What did you kill
us?" You cannot bear that guilt. So you
have to keep on moving forward. You rush
forward. Okay? Even if it kills you. All
right? So, so at this time we have so
much guilt. You either conquer the world
or you kill yourself. Your choice. And
that's why secret sites are so powerful,
guys. Okay? Not because they have
secrets. Okay? I I actually don't know
if they have secrets or not. All right?
But I imagine they don't have secrets,
but I imagine like they do so much evil
in the world that they can only do more
evil in order to escape the evil that
they've already done. Okay? It's as
though demons are chasing them. Does
that make sense, guys?
>> Yes.
>> All right. So, questions.
[snorts]
So I think I did not fully understand
the part which
the romance rape of those womens and
women's blame the sins on themselves
think that part I think it's a bit
confusing I think
>> okay so um first of all you need to
understand all this woman history is
nonsense okay none of it is true these
all just mythologies to create the woman
character
Okay. So the rape of the sab woman um
didn't really happen but what the custom
is if I go kill you I kill you and I
steal your wife. Okay. So so so it is a
metaphor for war. That does that make
sense? Okay. [snorts]
Okay. And um but what what this is
saying is like if you go and kill your
enemy and you steal his wife, the wife
will thank you. All right. So it's
creating this mythology.
All [clears throat] right.
>> But why would the wife thank you? Like
you
>> the wife won't thank you. The wife will
hate you. But do you care? Not. You
don't care. Okay. The winners write the
history. Do you understand?
>> When you become a slave, you are not
allowed to speak. You're not allowed to
think for yourself. You have to do
whatever the man tells you to do. Right?
Does that make sense? Mhm.
>> So even though you feel hate for the man
who's killed your family, you're now a
slave. So if you lost your soul and if
you lost your soul, it means I can do
whatever I want to your mind as well as
your body. Okay? So this is the Roman
way. And guys, um it's no different from
any empire that emerged after the
Romans. Okay? The British Empire is the
same way. The American Empire is the
same way as well in that if we conquer
you, we can now implant anything into
your soul because your soul is now ours.
Okay? So if you go to Germany and you
see what's you talk to Germans, the
Germans will tell you, "Oh, we are the
worst people in the world. We're the
most evil people in the world. We did
the Holocaust. We started World War I.
We started World War II. If you give us
any like opportunity, we'll start wars
for no reason." Okay? You go to Japan,
same thing.
Okay. So, the winners write the history
and the losers have to accept this
history. [snorts] Okay. Does that make
sense? Any more questions, guys?
Um, I remember when you were talking
about Julius Caesar, you said the the
only reason why he survived was because
or like [clears throat] survived the
Holocaust. Uh, not the Holocaust, but
like um uh people in Rome were being
killed, I think. and he was able to
survive because his father had a lot of
money, had a lot of wealth. But you also
mentioned that he was a part of the
populace. So how does that add up?
>> Okay. Yeah, that's a good question.
Okay. So to remind you, okay, the
conflict arises between upper nobility
and lower nobility. So upper nobility
are just the optimist people like I have
all the power. Lower nobility are the
children who are like I want the status.
Okay. So, so yes, Julius Caesar did come
from a very wealthy family, but he
didn't have status.
>> Okay.
>> Okay. So, money and status are not the
same thing. And that that's why there's
a civil wars because the people who were
part of elite aren't able to access
power. So, they scheme on how to access
power. So, look at Donald Trump. Okay?
Donald Trump has money but he doesn't
have power. That's why he ran for the
for presidency. Okay? Does it does it
make sense? Okay. So remember all these
conflicts that happen in the world are
always between upper nobility and low
nobility. Between the have a lot and the
have some but want some more. Okay? It's
never between rich and poor. The poor
don't do anything. Okay? The the poor
just like I'm poor. I'm useless. I'll
just sit and die. Okay? That's that's
what poor people are like. Middle class
people, rich people are like, you know,
I want more. Okay?
>> They're aspirational.
Is that clear? Okay. But I think if the
middle class like if they want more the
more higher class they will not allow
the middle class to
they won't allow them to have more like
they will suppress them.
>> Yeah. And that's what creates a French
revolution. Okay.
>> Oh.
>> All right.
All right. Any any more questions, guys?
Okay. Great. So, remember this is the
Roman Empire. We've done the Roman
Empire and it's an empire based on hate
and people's lives under the Roman
Empire. It's just terrible. There's
massive slavery. There's massive debt.
There's massive corruption. And so now
we'll emerge
um another poet prophet named Jesus to
try to redeem people. Okay. So we'll
discuss Jesus next class.